[Music]
det make some noise right now Jamie Foxx
got the party started when he hosted the
2018 Det Awards his opening monologue
celebrated Black Panther and even had an
assist from Michael B Jordan who recited
one of his character kill mongers most
memorable lines burning the oceans with
my ancestors cuz they jumped from the
ships cuz they knew that death was
better than bondage Jamie also reminded
us what an incredible voice he has
singing in Anita Baker classic before
she accepted the Lifetime Achievement
Award
[Music]
the evening was full of socially
conscious moments John Legend honored
real-life heroes while rapper Meek Mill
who was recently released from prison
delivered a powerful performance and of
course it wouldn't be an award show
without a few head-scratching moments
like this one from rapper offset that
had fans wondering did he and cardi B
secretly get married
thank God I thank my wife you should
thank yours
and here's reality star Alexis Skye
she certainly turned a lot of heads in
this revealing ensemble
[Music]